[Music]
i don't see any strawberries i know i
saw them well
maybe they ran away because they were
intimidated by this
this is the baby's learning everything
this is when it imprints
you know
i'm not careful all of a sudden the baby
thinks that his refrigerator is his
father
is that what happened to you i'll tell
you what happened to me
tell you what happened to me i didn't
see my father for the first two years of
his life
of his life
can't really explain what i'm feeling
but i like it
[Music]
i'm good you guys good
could that have been
a more
dance-appropriate sort of
there we go
oh my god your face was so funny
i mean i i'm feeling that it's it's very
full so i don't think she's been
releasing at all you're definitely
feeling that
the baby should grab on to that i think
she will so like a c
very funny over there
so just grab on to it grab them and i
squeeze it that hard yeah that hard yeah
really feel it it's getting repetitive i
think we got it
[Laughter]
look i can't legally watch this unfold
it comes dangerously close to
prostitution i want eye contact do you
understand how rare that is in nature
i am not some farm animal
hey
hey out of curiosity do you have any
other characters oh i'm working on
scranton strangler
um i'm gonna get you what do you think
[Laughter]
oh i'm working on a new one scranton
strangler
i'm gonna kill you
oh i'm working on the scranton strangler
don't start laughing
i'm working
i'm working on a new one scranton
strangler
i'm kidding
you now you're with the labby kelly is
even worse than daryl
if you'd have told me this morning
that today i'd be creating a monster
capable of my own destruction
i thought you were referring to the bull
we're trying to reanimate
[Laughter]
okay you know what jim i am taking you
off this account for unrelated
don't you smirk at me
okay
okay you know what jim
get your tongue in your face
um okay you know what jim i am taking
you off his account for unrelated
reasons
he was really close to you
he was really close just let him flirt
with her
people meet each other all sorts of ways
who are we to stand in the way pam you
know he's not gonna get anywhere and you
know he's gonna blow our sail who cares
it's not that huge of sale
the schwab
pam you know he's not gonna get anywhere
and you know he's gonna blow our sail
who cares it's not that huge of sale the
schwab guy does
this here is a radon test kit okay i'll
be putting them everywhere and
please don't throw these out
this is a radon test kit
please don't throw these out
see them all over the office
[Laughter]
[Music]
mommy
[Laughter]
that's
okay
random
all right all right and
wait for it
ow
okay
and hacha
i gave myself a front wedgie
okay
can we
yeah let's just let's pick up so he
doesn't have to keep resetting
i think you have to admit you flipped
out a little bit
i think you should stop talking now
i just
wanna she's still a little sore are you
sitting on your nose
[Laughter]
i think that mom she's just a little
sore still
yeah but your donut huh
it's not like i'm meeting anyone on chat
roulette
i was so southern did you hear it oh my
goodness it's not like i'm meeting
anyone on chat roulette i do declare
rhett i want to take care of this
invoice okay
uh copies and triplicate right back to
mr bernard dog
okay
you know what i wouldn't want you to get
tired walking around all day
who is it
who is it michael
hi
you say hi
[Laughter]
what's your blood type o negative
universal donor universal donor
you have to have sex with a woman
then sex with a man
and then just compare the two
preferably
in the same night
would you consider nope taking that
bullet for me
how do we figure this out well you just
have to sleep with a woman
i can do that and then sleep with a man
and then just compare when you think
about both
what are you free
sorry
[Laughter]
so i'll see you at the wedding oh yeah
okay
okay
bye
hey hi
[Laughter]
let me give it a whirl here no i really
want to talk i want to do
hello well that's great
people were there all alone
don't really too tired to do this me too
then let's just not do it do you have
any idea that risky
sorry what you did that was fun what
i'm sorry just thinking a lot
i'ma tell them you guys sexually
harassed my sister sexually
no judge is gonna believe that
okay all right
um
uh
oh guys okay look we could we could file
complaints against each other
that was good
all right fine i'll just tell them you
guys sexually harassed my sis
you know we can just call it even move
on with our lives
hey look
we could all fall complaints against
each other
no secret crying he hasn't even opened
the tissue box
no secret crying
lovely so we're gonna go with the most
logical thing is that he matured
overnight
wait for it
hold on
i can sit on your lap you can sit on my
lap all you want because i am a male
santa and that is something that phyllis
cannot do oh my god oh this is really
comfortable
okay
tell me what you want little boy
oh i don't know
i didn't know you were gonna ask me that
what did you think was going to happen i
didn't know
no one's ever let me sit on their lap
before hurry up just say some toys
can
can you give me some choices oh my god
kevin please
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
what would you like for christmas little
kevin
i don't know
i didn't know you were gonna ask me that
well what did you think was going to
happen here
i'm sorry
all right
you